[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 300 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف
سوريا تعود لمقعدها العربيه بشروط لجنه
اتصال تعمل على حل شامل للازمه ودمشق ترحب
[موسيقى]
للتحرك العربي السريع والمؤثر حاليا
دعم عربي للمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
للحل في السودان وممثل البرهان وحميتي
يبحثان يبحثون وقف النار في محادثات جدا
[موسيقى]
موسكو تتهم واشنطن بدعم الارهاب بعد تصريح
لمسؤول اوكراني قال ان بلاده ستقتل الروس
في اي مكان حتى النصر
وسيكون لدينا ايضا في 360
رغم مشاكله القانونيه المتلاحقه استطلاعات
الراي تعطي التقدم لترامب على بايدن بفارق
ست نقاط
[موسيقى]
12 عاما من التعليق انتهت استعدت سوريا
مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه والذي خسرته
جراء الحرب التي اندلعت في 2011 لكن قرار
الجامعه العربيه لم يتوقف عند حدود قرار
العوده بل شكلت لجنه اتصال وزاريه من
الاردن والسعوديه والعراق ولبنان ومصر
وامين عام الجامعه العربيه بهدف استمرار
الحوار مع دمشق للتوصل الى حل شامل للازمه
السوريه لخصت الجامعه العربيه الامر قائله
ان القرار بشان سوريا بدايه حركه وليست
نهايه المطاف
اتخذت الدول العربيه قرارا باستئناف
مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وجميع
المنظمات والاجهزه التابعه لها اعتبارا من
اليوم 7 مايو 2023
اكرر مجددا على ضروره وفاء كل من الحكومه
السوريه والقوه الوطنيه والمكونات السوريه
والمجتمع الدولي والدول المعنيه بالازمه
بالتزاماتها كل اتجاه الاخر
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد
ابو الغيط قال ان الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد من حقه المشاركه في اجتماع القمه
المقبل اذا رغب في ذلك
سوريا
ابتداء من مسائل اليوم هي عدو كامل
العضويه بالجامعه العربيه ومن صباح غد لهم
الحق في شغل اي مقعد يشاركون فيه عندما
توجه الدعوه من قبل الدوله الضيافه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واذا ما رغب ان
يشارك فسوف يشارك
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء السوري حسين
عرنوس ان سوريا مقبله على مرحله من
الانفتاح والتعاون البناء والمنتج معربا
عن امله في ان تكون المرحله المقبله مقدمه
لانتهاء معاناه السوريين جراء العقوبات
وحرمانهم من الاستفاده من مقدراتهم
وثرواتهم على حد وصفه
بين التعليق في 2011 والعوده في 20 23 مر
اكثر من عقد التقرير الاتي يرصد لنا ما
كان بين التاريخين
12 سنه كانت كافيه لعوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه
الحكايه بدات مع اندلاع اعمال العنف في
البلاد عام 2011 في الاجتماع الشهير
لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في القاهره تم
اقرار تعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه لحين
التزام الحكومه السوريه بتنفيذ بنود
المبادره العربيه تعليق مشاركه وفد حكومه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماع
جامعه مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه القرار
حينها طالب الدول العربيه بسحب سفرائها من
دمشق لكنه اعتبر ذلك امرا سياديا لكل دوله
وزراء الخارجيه العرب اتفقوا ايضا وقتئذ
على توقيع عقوبات اقتصاديه وسياسيه على
الحكومه السوريه مندوب سوريا لدى الجامعه
وصفحينها القرار بغير القانوني والمخالف
لميثاقها ونظامها الداخلي بعد هذا القرار
الذي تم اتخاذه اليوم بشكل غير قانوني
وبشكل غير ميثاقي منذ ذلك الوقت بقي كرسي
سوريا شاغرا قمه بعد اخرى واجتماعا بعد
اخر ومن القاهره ايضا وزراء الخارجيه
العرب التفقوا على عوده مشروطه لسوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه وفق مبدا الخطوه مقابل
الخطوه مع ضروره اتخاذ خطوات عمليه وفاعله
للتدرج نحو حل الازمه السوريه اتخذت الدول
العربيه قرارا باستئناف مشاركه وفد
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعات
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
اعتبارا من اليوم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه قالت ان واشنطن تتفهم سعي
الشركاء للتواصل للتواصل المباشر مع
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد لمزيد من الضغط
لحل الازمه السوريه واضافت الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها تشكك برغبه بشار الاسد بحل
الازمه في سوريا لكنها تتفق مع شركاء
العرب حول الاهداف النهائيه وقالت انها
تعتقد انه من المبكر عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه
من القاهره السفير صلاح حليمه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الاسبق ونائب رئيس المجلس المصري
للشؤون الافريقيه اهلا بكم معنا ساعات
السفير على شاشه العربيه ما الذي تعنيه
تحديدا هذه العوده في هذا التوقيت والرغمه
انتقاد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعدم
ارادتها ذلك كما تقول
العوده هي عوده
عوده سوريا الى مقادها في الجامعه العربيه
وممارسه نشاطها في كافه اجهزه ومؤسسات
الجامعه
المعنيه من ناحيه اخرى هذه العوده في نفس
الوقت
مرتبطه
بعمليه
متبادله ما بين الجانبين طبقا لبيان عمان
الخاص بان تكون هناك خطوه مقابلها خطوه
اخرى وهذا يعني انه في هذه العضويه يجب ان
يكون هناك اجراءات
تتخذها تتخذها سوريا في مقابل الخطوه التي
تم اتخاذها من جانب الجامعه العربيه هناك
مجموعه اتصال تم تشكيلها من خمس دول
ومعظمها معني بالاوضاع الانسانيه بالدرجه
الاولى لمتابعه تنفيذ التعهدات والال التي
وردت في بيان عمان يعني المحاولات العربيه
مع سوريا لتغيير بوصله يعني سياساتها في
احيان كثيره فشلت
كيف يعني يمكن ان نبني توقعاتنا على طبيعه
العلاقه مستقبلا بين العالم العربي وسوريا
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الداخلي فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقه مع ايران
فيما له علاقه بالتهريب
الحقيقه الوارده في سوريا يعني يتسم
بالتعقيد الشديد الازمه السوريه لها ابعاد
سياسيه وابعاد امنيه وابعاد ايضا اقتصاديه
وابعاد انسانيه في غايه الاهميه
التحرك الاخيره الذي جاء على خلفيه هذا
القرار كان هناك تحرك من جانب السعوديه
بصفه خاصه في اطار الرباعيه الدولي
الرباعيه العربيه وكان هناك اتصالات
زيارات من جانب الاسد الى الامارات ثم
اتصالات على المستوى الوزاري بين السعوديه
وسوريا وبين مصر وسوريا ثم عقدت اجتماعات
في جده للرباعيه العربيه بالاضافه الى
مجلس التعاون الخليجي وايضا في عمان
للرباعيه العربيه مصر والسعوديه وايضا
العراق والاردن ومن خلال هذه الاجتماعات
خاصه على ضوء الخلفيه الخاصه بالزلزال
الذي حدث في سوريا وتركيا ثم
المباراه التي شهدتها العلاقات خاصه
السعوديه مع دول الجوار الاقليم العربي
وهي تركيا وايران وايضا ما حدث من تطورات
على مستوى العلاقات ما بين السعوديه
والدول
العظمى ورغم ذلك يقول سيد ابو الغيط بانه
هذا القرار
اعذرني على المقاطعه بس نذكر بانه السيد
احمد ابو الغيط يقول بانه هذا القرار لا
يعني اعاده الدول العربيه لعلاقاتها مع
دمشق مشيرا الى ان هذا قرار سيادي تتخذه
كل دوله نستمعتم نعود اليك
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سياجي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا
بناء عليه ما زال بامكاننا ان نسال او يجب
ان نسال سعد السفير هل كان قرار طرد سوريا
انذاك متسرعا خاطئا
يعني
انجرارا وراء لحظه تاريخيه معينه
كان قرار تعليق عضويه سوريا ربما اذا
رجعنا الى الميثاق ليس هناك نص يتعلق
بالتعليق وانما هو كان اجراء اجتهادي
ولذلك المندوب السوري انتقد هذا الامر
وذكر انه لا يخالف المساق وانه اجراك غير
قانوني ايضا فيما يتعلق بعده العلاقات او
تطبيق العلاقات مع سوريا قررت تعليق
العضويه كانوا معه قرار اخر ايضا يتعلق
بعمليه انه عمل سيادي لكل دوله عربيه في
ان تسحب سفراء سفرها من سوريا كان هناك
مطلب في من الجامعه العربيه يدعو الى سحب
سفراء الدول العربيه من سوريا لكنه ايضا
اعتبر قرار سيادي وبالتالي ظل هناك بعض
الدول العربيه على علاقه بسوريا خلال هذه
الفتره وبعضها استانف هذه العلاقات ايضا
في مرحله التاليه
اما فيما يتعلق
بالمجموعه الاتصال او المجموعه التي شكلت
الخماسيه فهي تتعلق
بمتابعه تنفيذ الاجراءات التي التزمت بها
سوريا في اتفاق في بيان عمان
كخطوه خطوه وهذا ما يفسر حديث معالي
الامين العام بان هذا ليست نهايه المطاف
انما هي بدايه لمرحله يتعين على سوريا في
خلال هذه الفتره في اطار زمني معين ان
تتخذ من الخطوات التي يتعين عليها تنفيذها
لهذا ببيان عمان تمام اسعد سفير شكرا
لوجودك معنا الليله السفير صلاح حليمه
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الاسبق ونائب رئيس
المجلس المصري للشؤون الافريقيه من
القاهره تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ايضا في العربيه 360
باريس اعتذرت لروما عن اهانه ميلوني لكن
ايطاليا ما تزال غاضبه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى ملف السودان اعتبر
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط ان المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
الهادفه الى التوصل لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان تستحق الدعم وكان ابو
الغيط تلقى رساله من الاطراف الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان حول الدوري
المتوقع من الجامعه لوقف المعارك وطالبت
هذه الاطراف ابو الغيط بالتوصل مع قيادات
الجيش والدعم السريع بالتواصل معها لوقف
الحرب ورفض التدخلات الخارجيه كما طالبوه
بحذف الطرفين على اتاحه وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه وتنفيذ برنامج الاصلاحي يفضي
الانتخابات عامه في اقرب وقت
وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري كان اعلن
عن تشكيل لجنه اتصال عربيه خاصه بالسودان
لوقف القتال وضمان سلامه الممرات الامنه
في البلاد
هناك اهميه وضروره بالغه للتحرك العربي
السريع والمؤثر حاليا ومن هنا جاء قرار
انشاء لجنه اتصال من بين اعضاء الجامعه
العربيه
تهدف لوقف اطلاق النار والسماح بالممرات
الانسانيه لاحتياجات المدنيين والحفاظ على
مؤسسات الدوله وعدم تعريضها للخطر
الانهيار الذي يهددها حاليا
في التطورات الميدانيه افاد مراسل العربيه
في الخرطوم بان اشتباكات دارت في منطقه
القصر الرئاسي بين الجيش وقوه الدعم كما
سمعت اصوات اطلاق النار في محيط مطار
الخرطوم ومحيط قياده الجيش حيث اطلقت قوات
الدعم السريع المضادات الارضيه على طائرات
الاستكشاف
[موسيقى]
انما تعمل الوساطات الدوليه والاقليميه
على التهدئه السياسيه بين طرفين نزاع في
السودان تعكس المجريات على الارض صوره
مختلفه فالقتال في السودان ما زال مستمرا
رغم الهدنه الطويله لتسمع اصوات
الاشتباكات جنوب ووسط العاصمه الخرطوم
بالاخص في منطقه السوق العروي ومحيط
المطار وافاد شهود عيان بتحليق طائرات
حربيه وسماع يدوي انفجار قوي واصوات اسلحه
ثقيله في محيط القصر الرئاسي والقياده
العامه للجيش كما شنت الطائرات ضربات جويه
في حي الرياض بالخرطوم لم ينحصر باستمرار
الصراع في تلك المنطقه بل سمع دوي
انفجارات وتحليق للطيران الحربي في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري واشتباكات متفرقه في منطقتي
كافوري وشرق النيل بالاضافه لاصوات مضادات
الطيران في اندرمان
اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين النزاع بخرق
الهدنه فالجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بارسال تعزيزات للخرطوم بينما اكدت
الجهه الاخرى شن غارات من قبل الجيش
السوداني على مناطق لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي بدورها حاولت استهداف قياده قوات
الدفاع الجوي
وفي ظل الاشتباكات المستمره فتح الباب
امام عمليات النهب والحرق على وجه الخصوص
في المنطقه الصناعيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وضع يعكس تصريحات طرفي الصراع باستعدادهما
لمناقشه الهدنه والوضع الانساني دون
الالتزام بوقف النهائي لاطلاق النار ايفا
عمر العربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
معنا الان هاتفيا من امدرمان صحفي في مكتب
العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر اهلا بك
معنا شهدي الاوضاع الميدانيه اليوم والان
في السودان عموما من خلال رصدك وفي تحديدا
حيث انت
مرحبا طاهر اليوم هدات حاليا يمكن الدخول
بان هناك حاله من الهدوء بعد اليوم عاطف
شهد اشتباكات شهيده قارات متواصله الطيران
الحربي في حل فيها سمعنا اليوم ذوي انفجار
يكون هو الاول من النوع الذي نستمع له
وحدث اهتزاز يعني لدرجه وصل اهتزاز في
المنازل وما هي الا ذلك
هذا الدوي علمنا فيما بعد انه هذه منطقه
الخرطوم بحري حيث نفذ الطيران الحربي
اليوم قصفا باتجاه سلاح المظلات التي هو
الان الوحده الطبيه قوات الدعم السريع
وكذلك في منطقه حله حمد جنوبي مدينه بحريه
اليوم كذلك الشهيد اشتباكات بحثا ما علمنا
في محيط القصر الجمهوري
السوق العربي هو يوم كان يعني دعنا نقول
بانه اكثر اكثر انفجارات من يعمل الماضي
برغم ذلك يعني انعكست هذه الظروف وهذه
الايام الاخيره يعني فراجا على الناس يعني
اكثر من ايام الحرب الاولى اقصد بطبيعه
الحال
نعم نعم طاهر المواطنين ازدادت حركتهم في
الشوارع رغم الظروف الصعبه فيما يلي شحال
الوقود صعوبه الحركه صعوبه المواصلات حاله
السيوله الامنيه طاهر واستمرار عمليات
السلبي والنعم من قبل المجموعات المجموعات
المتفلته عدم شعور الرقم وعدم شعور الناس
بالامان ولكن السودانيين يجدون انفسهم
مضطرين وتحديدا داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
للخروج فبعضهم بدا في مباشره اعماله
وبالاخص اصحاب المهن اليوميه الذين
يحتاجونه في حياتهم على
المعاش اليومي من حلاقين وخلاف هؤلاء
يباشر واعمارهم وجدوا انفسهم مضطرين غير
قادرين على على البغاسي في منازلهم اكثر
من
اكثر من فتره بقائه في المنازل شكرا جزيلا
لك شهدي نادر من اندرمان الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه هناك
الخرطوم
المحطه الوسطى
على المحطه الوسطى
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان وجهها مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه بتقديم مساعدات الانسانيه
متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار لصالح الشعب
السوداني كما وجه الملك سلمان والامير
محمد بن سلمان بتنظيم حمله شعبيه عبر منصه
ساهم وذلك لتخفيف اثار الاوضاع التي يمر
بها الشعب السوداني حاليا
وقد رصدت كاميرا العربيه استمرار الجسر
الجوي لعمليات اجلاء الرعايه من جنسيات
مختلفه من بورتسودان الى جده عبر طائرات
عسكريه تابعه للقوات الجويه السعوديه هذا
وقد نفذت قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
مدينه جده غرب السعوديه اكثر من 70 رحله
جويه من الرابع والعشرين من شهر ابريل
الماضي
[موسيقى]
هذه هي الطائره الثانيه التي تصل اليوم
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه من نوع
سي 1 30 التابعه للقوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه وهي قادمه من بورتسودان تحمل على
متنها قرابه السبعين شخص من جنسيات مختلفه
ضمننا عمليات اجلاء الرعايه من السودان
الى مدينتي جده
[موسيقى]
هنا لحظه نزول الرعايه من الطائره
العسكريه التابعه للقوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه
وهم يحملون جنسيات متعدده هنا قائد قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه اللواء عبد الله
الزهراني وكذلك السفير البنجلاديشي لدى
السعوديه وكذلك عدد من القاده وايضا
البعثات الدبلوماسيه المعتمده
لدى السعوديه
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه يتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم هنا في منصات الجوازات وتقنيات
حديثه موفره من اجل سرعه انهاء الاجراءات
النقيب عبد الرحمن القثامي من مركز
الاعلامي في مديريه في المديريه العامه
للجوازات كيف يتم انهاء اجراءات الرعايه
الذين لا يحملون ثبوتات لديهم ما تزال
المدير العامه للجوازات مستمره في استقبال
الرعايه من الدول الشقيقه والصديقه
والقادمين الى المملكه من خلال رحلات
النقل الجوي وكذلك الرحلات عبر السفن
البحريه يتم التحقق من الرعايه والركاب
القادمين والذين لا يحملوا الوثائق السفر
من جنسياتهم وتحديد الجنسيات بعد ذلك يتم
التواصل مع ممثلياتهم الملحقيات بلدانهم
لاصدار وثائق سفر لهم عند صدور وثائق
السفر يتم تدوينها في انظمه الحاسب الالي
واصدار التاشيرات اللازمه لهم وتسهيل
دخولهم الى المملكه تمهيدا لمغادرتهم الى
اوطانهم اكثر من 13 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه
وصلوا الى جده بعد عمليات اجلال من قبل
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه والقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وفرقطات وسفن
اجنبيه
كذلك تم مغادره معظمهم الى بلدانهم بعد
التنسيق مع بعثاتهم الدبلوماسيه لقناه
العربيه هاني الصفيان جده
كانت الامارات رحبت بالمحادثات بين ممثلين
عن القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع في مدينه جده وثمنته الخارجيه
الاماراتيه في بيان لها دور السعوديه
وامريكا والجهودا التي قامت بها لانجاح
الحوار مؤكده اهميه التوصل الى توافق
لانهاء الازمه بين الاطراف وتجنيب الشعب
السوداني المزيد من المعاناه
[موسيقى]
في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه اعتبرت المتحدثه
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا خرافا
ان نظام اكد من خلال التصريحات مسؤوليه ان
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن راعيه
للارهاب على حد قولها واستشهدت زخرفه برد
مدير الاستخبارات بوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه كيريل بودانوف على سؤال صحفيه
حول دوري اوكرانيا في مقتل صحفي الروسيه
داريا حيث اجاب بان اوكرانيا قتلت وستقتل
الروس في اي مكان حتى تحقق نصر الكامل
الاغتيالات او محاولات قتل المؤيدين للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تعود من جديد الى
روسيا وغالبا ما تكون اوكرانيا المتهمه
الاستهداف الثالث كان من نصيب الكاتب
والسياسي القومي الروسي البارز زخار الذي
اصيب في مدينه
بغرب روسيا بتفجير عبوه ناسفه قتل جراءها
سائق السياسي الروسي الخارجيه الروسيه
وصفت الحادث بالعمل الارهابي فيما احتجزت
سلطات الروسيه رجلا قالت انه اعترف بتنفيذ
الهجوم بامر من المخابرات الاوكرانيه على
طريق كان يسلكه الرجل قبل ذلك وتحديدا في
الثاني من الشهر الماضي قتل المدون
العسكري مكسيم فوفوبيين في تفجير تمثال
مفخ اهدي له في مقهى بمدينه اثناء فعاليه
كان يحضرها هناك السلطات اوقفت امراه
روسيه اقرت بانها قدمت الى الضحيه التمثال
الذي سبب ايضا في اصابه 30 شخصا لكن حينها
اتهمت موسكو انصار المعارض الروسي المسجون
الكسنافالني الاستهداف الاول منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وقع العام الماضي عندما
قتلت داريا دوجينا ابنه العالم السياسي
الروسي وشخصيه العامه
في ضواحي موسكو في العشرين من اغسطس حينها
قال الخبراء خبراء في الشان الروسي قالوا
ان المستهدف من وراء الهجوم والدها رغم
تاكيدهم على ان عملها الصحفي ونشاطها
السياسي تجعلها مستهدفه بشكل اكبر منه
وفي التطورات الميدانيه اعلن قائد مجموعه
فاجنر تلقيه اوامره من القياده الروسيه
بالقتال في ضخمه اضافه الى تعهدها بتوفير
الاسلحه والذخيره تلك التي تحتاجها
للاستمرار بالقتال كما كان يطالبه
تلقينا بين عشيه وضحاها امرا بالقتال لاول
مره اذا تخطينا المعلومات السريه فاننا
حصلنا على وعد بالذخيره والاسلحه بقدر ما
نحتاجه لمواصله عملياتنا العسكريه لقد
وعدنا بتوفير كل ما هو ضروري لمنع العدو
من قطع الامدادات علينا لقد طلب منا
التصرف باخمت بما نراه ضروريا والتنسيق مع
الجنرال الروسي سرجي في كل ما يتعلق
بالقرارات الخاصه بالتنسيق بين فاجنر
ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه وهو جنرال في الجيش
الروسي يعرف كيف يقاتل
بائع نقانق بسجل اجرامي بات احد اقوى
شخصيات الكرملين يتحدى المؤسسه العسكريه
وينتقدها على نيه مره تلو الاخرى قائد
فاجنر يفجن بروجين نجح كبائع نقانق في
مدينه بوتين
اوائل التسعينيات ليفتتح مطعما راقيا يدعى
ولحسن حظه بات مطعم الرئيس الروسي المفضل
اصبح بريجوجين يعمل على توصيل طلبات
الطعام وخدمات الضيافه لحفلات الكريملين
ومن ثم حفله عيد ميلاد بوتين عام 2003
فكسب لقب طباخ بوتين نجح الرجل في توسيع
دائره علاقاته داخل الكرمنين ليكتسب عقودا
حكوميه لتوفير الطعام للمدارس الروسيه
وللجيش الروسي فاصبح من اثرياء روسيا
ومع المزيد من الاموال تبدل نمط حياته
فاصبح يمتلك قصرا في سان بطرسبورغ ويختن
وطائره خاصه ومهبطا للطائرات المروحيه
بدات علاقته مع قاده الجيش تتوتر في عام
2015 فتح الباب امام المنبوذين من الجيش
وحتى المساجين رواتب مغريه والحريه مقابل
سته اشهر من الخدمه في جبهه فاجنر تصرفات
اغضبت رئيس هيئه الاركان فاليريج راسموف
ليعرقل فوز بريكوجين بعقود حصريه لتموين
الجيش منذ 2018
قبل اشهر اصدر البرلمان الروسي بتشجيع من
الجيش اصدر قانونا ينظم عمل شركات الخاصه
الا ان قائد فاجنر رفض القرار متسائلا عن
الهدف من تنظيم عمل شركه تدار بكفاءه
عاليه في العام الماضي قالت واشنطن ان ابن
بروجين بافل حارب مع باغنار في سوريا وحصل
على جائزه الصليب الاسود
في عده مناطق قتاليه حول العالم
ظهر مرتزقه بادنر اتهموا بتنفيذ الاعمال
القذره التي لا تريد موسكو التورط فيها
انكر بروجين علاقته بالشركه مرارا قبل ان
يعترف في سبتمبر العام الماضي بعد انخراط
المجموعه في حرب اوكرانيا
معنى من الهاتف عبر الهاتف من الرياض
دكتور سامي المتحدث باسم مركز الملك سلمان
الانسانيه بالعوده الى موضوع المساعدات
مساعدات مركز الملك سلمان للسودان وهنا
نريد ان نرحب بك اولا دكتور نريد ان نسال
عن طبيعه هذه المساعدات التي قدمت حتى
الان او التي ستقدم
حياكم الله استاذ
مشاهدينا الكرام نعم المساعدات تركز في
هذه المرحله على الاولويات في الاحتياج
الانساني وستكون في القطاعات من اهم قطاع
المساعدات الطبيه والتي سوف تعمل على سد
الاحتياجات في المستشفيات التي تقدم
الخدمات لعلاج حول المصابين كذلك سوف تكون
هناك مساعدات غذائيه تشمل سينار غذائيه
معياريه والمناسبعين كيلو جرام تكفي لاسره
مكونه من سبعه اشخاص لمده شهر كامل هذه
المساعدات الغذائيه سوف تغطي مناطق
الاحتياج في جميع ولايات السودان كذلك
باذن الله عز وجل هذه المساعدات لغايه
تستهدف
مناطق النزوح واحتياجات النازحين
والمتضررين في على الموارد وكذلك
المجتمعات المضيفه كذلك المساعدات سوف
تشمل باذن الله عز وجل
المساعدات الايوائيه من ناحيه توفير كل ما
يحتاجه لواء قطاع اللواء من خيام او
الحقائدي وغيرها هذه هي المرحله الاولى
سوف يكون هناك فريق كذلك يرافق هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه لتقييم الاحتياج
الانسان كذلك لمتابعه المشهد الانساني
وتطوراتها الاحتياج اول باول لمحاوله
مواكبه هذه المتغيرات وان يكون هذا التدخل
باذن الله عز وجل
اثر يركز على الاولويات
في ارقام دكتور لكم بلغ مثلا اجمالي
مساعدات حتى الان او كم متوقع ان يبلغ
نحن سوف نبدا هذه الحمله باذن الله عز وجل
حسب التوجيه السهم الكريم
سوف تبدا هذه الحمله باذن الله عز وجل غدا
نحن نستهدف في المرحله الاولى مناطق
النزوح
قد يعني ليس هناك الحقيقه تقارير دقيقه
لكن تقارير الاوليه التي وردتنا هل هناك
400 الف تقريبا نازح داخل السودان هناك
اكثر من 60 الف
لاجئ عبروا
الدول المجاوره سوف تكون هو المستهدف
الاول لنا هذه الاعداد لكن باذن الله عز
وجل سوف يمتد باذن الله عز وجل العمل الى
المناطق الاكثر احتياجا سوف نركز على
المناطق التي نستطيع الوصول لها وتعتبر
امنه لدخول اصول المساعدات وكذلك في تسليم
هذه المساعدات في ايدي امينه تريد ان تقول
دكتور بانه هناك ضمانات لديكم
يعني توفير الغطاء لضمان ايصال هذه
المساعدات المستحقيها نعم
لا يعمل لوحده لكن يعمل عدد من الجهات
منها وزاره الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع وكذلك
جهات اخرى داخل المملكه السعوديه نعمتك
كامل للتنسيق لان يكون هذا التدخل فاعل
وان تصل هذه المساعدات باذن الله عز وجل
والحقيقه النقطه الاولى هي حمايه العاملين
في هذه المساعدات وحمايه المساعدات
والتاكد الحقيقه من انها تصل بامان
للمحتاجين وتحقق الاثر المرضي ومنهج باذن
الله عز وجل من الجيد ان ندعوا او نسدد
دعوه عبركم ايضا
للمساهمه في منصه ساهم من خلال التبرعات
هل يمكن يعني ان نضيف شيء على هذا الموضوع
من قبلكم
منصه سهل هي منصه الرقميه لجمع التبرعات
في مركز الملك سلمان كذلك هي موجوده على
التطبيقات
الهواتف الذكيه على الاندرويد
هذه المنصه تستقبل التبرعات وفيها حمل
الان بدات الان بجمع التبرعات بالاشق
المتضررين في الحمله الشعبيه السعوديه
لمساعده المتضررين لمشاهده الاشقاء في
السودان تستقبل هذه
المنصه جميع البطاقات وكذلك
هناك حسابات في مركز الملك سلمان يستطيع
من خلالها اي شخص ايداع لصالح هذه الحمله
هناك كذلك امكانيه
الحقيقه التبرع من خلال الشفات في مركز
الملك سلمان هناك رقم التواصل الموجود على
المنصه من خلال اي شخص ان يتواصل اذا كان
لديه اي مشكله في حاله التبرع لهنا اريد
ان اشاهد الحقيقه واشكر يعني القياده
الرشيده التي وجهت هذا التوجيه سامي
الكريم والتي دائما ما تتلمس الاحتياج
الانسان في الدول الشقيقه والصديقه وتوجه
رساله الاستجابه لصناعه التدخل شاهد وكذلك
تدعم هذا التدخل في عطاء ساخي كما راينا
100 مليون دولار مرحله اوليه كذلك الشكر
للمستمع السعودي الذي راينا منه دائما
الاستجابه والوقوف مع الاشقاء في الازمات
وذلك من خلال التفاعل الرائع مع الحملات
الشعبيه مع منصه بحمد الله عز وجل راي من
خلال تبرعات للاشقه في سوريا وتركيا بلغت
500 مليون ريال سعودي خلال شهر واحد فقط
بحمد الله عز وجل وهذا يسطر الحقيقه ويدل
دلاله واضحه على كرم
الشعب السعودي وفراده وكذلك
الحقيقه
التفاعل مع الاستجابه لما توجيهات القياده
الرشيده التي الاخير دائما ما في دعم
الاحتياج الانساني والوق وف مع المحتاجين
في انحاء العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور سامر الاسطيلي
المتحدث باسم مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والعمال الانسانيه من الرياض تحياتي اليك
اذا بين تاكيد اوكرانيا ونفي روسيا لاسقاط
صاروخها المتطور امس وعدم وجود طرف محايد
على الساحه تبدو حقيقه الامر غير واضحه
حتى الان نتحدث هنا عن الصاروخ الاسرع من
الصوت كينجال يعني خنجر باللغه الروسيه
وهو احد اسلحه الجيل الجديد للجيش الروسي
كنجال صاروخ باليستي يطلق من الجو وهو ما
يتركه مع وقود اكثر للاستخدامه للوصول الى
سرعات اعلى وهو من نوعيه صواريخ جو ارض
يمكن ان تصل سرعه هذا الصاروخ الى اثني
عشر الفا وثلاثمائه وخمسين كيلومترا في
الساعه الى
12,350 كم في الساعه مع قدرته على حمل
رؤوس حربيا نوويه او تقليديه نبقى على
الارض في اوكرانيا التي اعلنت اسقاط صاروخ
كنجال والوسيله منظومه صواريخ الامريكيه
التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا الشهر الم طبعا هذا
موضوع في اشكال كبير وليس مجرد خبر
المنظومه تعمل بنظام دفاع متعدد الطبقات
اي بامكانها اطلاق ثلاثه انواع مختلفه من
الصواريخ الاعتراضيه المصممه لتدمير انواع
مختلفه من التهديدات كالطائرات الحربيه
والمروحيات والصواريخ والمسيرات التحليلات
تشير الى ان اوكرانيا استخدمت
طراز باك ثلاثه من الذي يمكنه اسقاط
الطائرات المعاديه على مدى حوالي 65
كيلومترا والصواريخ الباليستيه على مسافه
35 كيلومترا وفي ظل غياب معلومات مؤكده
يرى خبراء ان ضرب صاروخ كنجال روسي بصاروخ
صعب ولكنه ليس مستحيلا معنى من القاهره
الان استاذ احمد في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه اهلا بك استاذ يعني البعض يذهب
الى انه
مستحيل او لناكل شبه مستحيل يعني
وليس فقط صعب ما رايك
مساء الخير استاذ طاهر اولا اهلا انا اتفق
بالفعل مع المقوله ان هو صعب لكنه ليس
مستحيلا لانه يعني هذا الامر مثير
للاهتمام ومثير للجدل في نفس الوقت يعني
لانه ليس فقط مساله انه يتم اعتراض صاروخ
فرض صوتي من منظومه باتروت الامريكيه
ولكنه تغيير ايضا في حسابات السياده
الجويه والتفوق الدفاع الجوي
وكل هذه الحسابات الروسيه وايضا الحسابات
من جانب كييف وبالتالي يعني بعتقد ان
الخبراء هنا بيستندوا الى تحليلات عديده
طالما انه لا توجد روايه رسميه على الاقل
من الجانب الامريكي بعض المسؤولين اشاره
الى ان هم يعني تعرفوا على الشظايا عن بعد
واكدوا ان هي بالفعل صواريخ صاروخ كنجال
لكن لم يتم
حسم هذا الامر من جانب البنتاجون على حسب
ظني حتى الان لكن من حيث المؤشرات مهم جدا
ان احنا نعرف انه على سبيل المثال حضرتك
كما ذكرت في التقرير انه بتستخدم ثلاث
مستويات من الصواريخ
المهم الباكستري لكن الاهم من كذا انه
الباكستري نفسها تحسنت في اللعبه الاخير
من العام 2021 لما تم تحديث انظمه الرادار
ووحده محرك الدفع نظام بيطلق عليه الام اس
اي وده نظام مهم جدا
وبيتعامل مع كافه الصواريخ وهنا معدل
السرعه ما بينه وما بين سرعه اطلاق
الميجو 31
للصاروخ الكنجال هو بيفوقه تلات مرات فهنا
الحزبه هي اللي مختلفه لصالح التفوق
الزمني الان الصاروخ بشكل اساسي اعذرني
على المقاطعه اذا اردت ان تتابع تفضل ولكن
اريد ان استفيد من الوقت المتبقي لاسال عن
التاثيرات السياسيه لهذا بغض النظر عما
يعني اذا حصل او لم يحصل هل ما دلالاته هل
هذا يعني تحضير لشيء ماء لم يحصل وان حصل
كيف سينعكس على المشهد العسكري
سؤال مهم لكن يعني فقط كنت اريد ان اضيف
ان هناك مؤشر المهم ان هو اوكرانيا بدات
تتحرك الان باريحيه شديده في اطلاق
الدرونز داخل العمق الروسي وفي جزيره
الكرم وفيلبرج في غيرها من هذه المواقع
الحساسه التي تصيب ايضا
مصفاه نافطه تصيف تصيب مدرج مطارات عسكريه
وماه ذلك هذه مساله مهمه للغايه المساله
الاخرى صاروخ كان يمكن ان يصيب مخازن
صواريخ موجوده في العمق الاوكراني
لديها يعني تحت العمق الخاص تحت سطح الارض
بحوالي 150 مترا هذه مساله كانت تجعل من
كينجال هو الصاروخ المفضل بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي رغم انها كانت تستخدمه استخدمت فقط
على مدار عام حوالي 50 صاروخ لكن من
الناحيه السياسيه مهم جدا انه عايز
الصاروخ تم استخدامه في اليوم التالي
بطبيعه الحال للهجوم على الكلام وبالتالي
كان هناك هدف مهم في كييف يعني هناك
محاوله لاستهدافه من الجانب الروسي للرد
على عمليات كيف لكن الان التحول يجري ما
بين السلاح الروسي الذي تعتبر الروسي هو
السلاح القارب صرخت انجاز صاروخ مهم من
بين ست صواريخ بالنسبه للاتفاق الصاروخ
الروسي لكن ايضا اعتراضاته الامريكيه
المحسنه الان الطرفان وجها لوجه بشكل او
باخر
المساله ايضا هنا تتعلق بتاجيل حمله
الربيع الى حد ما والتي لا يمكن ان نتوقع
انها ستثير بالشكل الذي كان منتظرا انه
المساله تتعلق فقط بيئه ارتباط الميدانيه
على الارض في مساحه
ولكن هذه المعادلات ايضا تتغير واصدر حديث
عن انه روسيا الان تقوم بعمليه اخلاء
ديموغرافي لاعاده كبير من السكان فيزا
بوروجا وفي خرسون هناك تباطؤ في عمليات
عسكريه في مواقع مهمه مسام
وغيره من هذه المحاور وبالتالي هذا
التباطؤ يعني ان هناك شيء ما وبالتالي
معادلات المعركه كلها معدله اشتباك شكل
التخطيط انا اعتقد ان هو يتغير الان في
هذه المرحله وانه يعني معركه الربيع التي
يجري الحديث عنها وانت اخرت عن التوقيت
المعلن لها لكن ايضا هناك حسابات سياسيه
اخرى بدا الخطاب الروسي يتجه الان الى
الحديث عن دور الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والناتو اكثر مما كان يتحدث عليه عنه في
الوقت السابق يتحدث عن اتهامات بعمليات في
العمق الروسي ايضا كما ذكرت حضرتك لعدد من
الشخصيات السياسيه وبالتالي المعركه لم
تعد فقط مجرد عمليات في الميدان بهذا
الشكل اذا نحن نتجه الى فصل جديد من
الاشتراك ما بين الطرفين والاطراف الاخرى
التي تدعم هذا الذي يكون مفتوح على كل
الاحتمالات
الاقليميه والدوليه بالتاكيد لك استاذ
احمد علي بالبحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الايطالي ان بلاده لا
تزال غير راضيه عن الاعتذارات التي قدمتها
باريس بعد ان اتهم وزير داخليتها روما
باساءه التعامل مع مساله تدفق المهاجرين
وطلب الوزير الحكومه الفرنسيه بتقديم
توضيحات دقيقه بخصوص موقفها تجاه هذه
التصريحات كان وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
جيرال دارمانم قال ان رئيسه الوزراء
الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني لم تتمكن من حل
مشاكل الهجره التي تم انتخابها على اساسها
في العربيه 360 ايضا
قلب رئيس الوزراء الياباني فطر لكن واشنطن
سعيده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان نابليونا و700 الف تركي شاركوا في
تجمعه الانتخابي اليوم في اسطنبول وقال
اردوغان ان اسطنبول لها اهميه كبيره في
الانتخابات مشيرا الى انها لو اختارته
سيفوز بالانتخابات
من ناحيه اخرى تعرض رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
الاكرم امام اوغلو لهجوم بالحجاره خلال
التجمع الانتخابي في ارضروم الشمال شرق
تركيا اكرم امام اوغلو المعارض لاردوغان
والذي يترشح كنائب للرئيس على بطاقه كمال
كليتش دار اوغلو المنافس الرئيس اردوغان
الشرطه بعدم حمايته اثناء تعرضه للهجوم
واعلن عودته الى اسطنبول
الى ذلك اتهم وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان
السويلم امام اوغلو بترتيب الهجوم في ار
دروم من اجل اغراض انتخابيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الانتخابات التركيه يخوض سته ملايين
ناخب شاب تجربه الانتخابات للمره الاولى
وهؤلاء من ضمن قرابه 13 مليون ناخب يطلق
عليهم اسم الجيلزي حيث يبلغ عدد الناخبين
الاجمالي
62.4 مليون نخب
رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الثاني عشر لتركيا
واكثر الزعماء حكما للبلاد كرئيس للوزراء
ورئيس الجمهوريه خلال عقدين من حكمه نشا
جيل كامل هو الجيل زد او جيل الالفيه الذي
لم يعرف حاكما غير اردوغان اكثر من سته
ملايين شاب سيصوتون للمره الاولى ومجمل
اعداد الجيلي زد يبلغ قرابه 13 مليون ناخب
وفق علماء اجتماع فان هذا الجيل لا يرتبط
بقائد معين اي انهم غير متعصبين لاي حزب
او مجموعه او فئه بل هم جيل متقلب ومتغير
بشكل يومي ضمن
نتحدث عن جيل له توجهات متغيره ومتضاربه
في الترجيح والاختيار نظرا لذلك اذا اردنا
التعرف على توجهات هذا الجيل في
الانتخابات يجب علينا الاعتماد على اخر
الاحصاءات التي تسبق الانتخابات بايام
قليله لان هذا الجيل يغير ارائه بشكل يومي
واذا اردنا تثبيت اصواتهم بصوره اقرب ما
تكون للواقع يجب ان نعتمد دوما على
المعلومات المحدثه عند اعداد هذا التقرير
قررنا اجراء مقابلات مع الشباب في احدى
جامعات اسطنبول لان الجامعات تضم مختلف
المشارب والاراء لذلك كان سؤال الشباب لمن
ستصوتون وما هي الاسباب التي دفعتهم
للاختيار
لست متاكدا بالضبط لكن اتصور باني ساصوت
لكمالك الجدار اوغلو لاني ارى ان الحكومه
الحاليه يجب ان تتغير
التركيين اذا نظرنا الى المسار السياسي
الحالي لتركيا واذا اردنا ان نعرف من
سيحسن الوضع الحالي فانني مازلت متردده
استطلاعات الراي تقول ان غالبيه هذا الجيل
لا يؤيد اردوغان انما يريد تغييرا في شكل
الحكم والياته بما يناسب تطلعاته لكن
الرئيس التركي لديه الكثير من الوعود
الانتخابيه لهذه الفئه ومن ضمنها تاسيس
بنك الشباب والاسره وتسهيل حصولهم على
قروض ومنح ماليه
وملايين الوظائف الجديده
فهل ينجح في استقطابهم صناديق الاقتراع في
الرابعه عشر من مايو ستجيب على هذا السؤال
تمثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي منبرا
اساسيا من منابر الدعايه والوصول الى جيل
الشباب لذلك انشا معظم المرشحين حسابات
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونخص بالذكر
هنا تطبيق التيك توك الذي لجا اليه مرشحون
رئاسه مؤخرا للوصول الى قلوب وعقول الشباب
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
والى ملف انتخابات اخرى وتحديدا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه فرغم كمل
مشكلات القانونيه التي تلاحقه الا ان
استطلاعا مشتركا
اظهر تقدم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن بسته نقاط
شعبيه بايدن عند ادنى مستوى منذ انتخابه
عام 2021
كشف استطلاع الراي اجرته واشنطن بوست واي
بي سي تفوق ترامب على بايدن
كما اظهرت نتائج الاستطلاع ان شعبيه بايدن
تراجعت بست نقاط مئويه بعد اعلان ترشحه
بخصوص السلامه العقليه والقدره على قياده
البلاد حصل بايدن على تاييد 33% فقط من
الناخبين
في المقابل يعتقد 64% من الذين تم
استطلاعهم ان ترامب في صحه جيده تؤهله
لولايه ثانيه شعبيه بايدن انخفضت في صفوف
الديمقراطيين حيث يفضل 58% منهم دعم مرشح
جديد للانتخابات
شكرا لليان في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
قلبي ينفطر عندما افكر فيما تسبب فيه
الحكم الاستعماري الياباني لبلادكم من
معاناه والم
التصريح هو لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
ويقصد بتصريحه فتره احتلال اليابان لكوريا
الجنوبيه بين 1910 و 1945 بالطبع صول
سعيده جدا بهذا التصريح ولكن واشنطن لا
تقل سعاده فقد رحبت بروح التعاون بين
البلدين ليس من اجل مصلحتهما الثنائيه
وانما من اجل مصلحه ثلاثيه هذه المره الا
وهي مواجهه تهديدات كوريا الشماليه
والمنافسه مع الصين
وفي صوره اليوم صحف انجلترا لا صوت يعلو
فوق صوت التتويج الملكي ولا صوره اهم من
صوره تشارلز ملكا اخيرا وبجواره الملكه
كملا لكن في انجلترا من فتش في صوره
القديمه ايضا لان المقارنه لن تنتهي ابدا
عاد هؤلاء لاربعين عاما مضت كانت تشارلز
ايضا في الصور لكن لم تكن هناك ملكه
بجواره وانما كانت ديانا اميره القلوب
في فيديو اليوم وخلال مراسم التتويج كان
هناك من يخوض معركه جانبيه احد الموسيقيين
العسكريين انشغل بافراغ الاته الموسيقيه
من مياه الامطار وسط ابتسامه بعض زملائه
وقلق البعض الاخر لان الامر لا يحتمل لا
يمكنك ان تخرج لحنا شاذا في مراسم التتويج
الملكيه حتى ولو كان المتهم حبات المطر
[موسيقى]
وبهذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 ولكن
اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع ومعكم اخبار الساعه
فعلا بعد قليل مع ميس ميسون مساء الخير
ماذا لديك مساء الخير طاهر طبعا عوده
سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه تطورات في
السودان اصدار الحكم باعدام مقاتل هشام
الهاشمي بالاضافه للعديد من الملفات
والاخبار ارجو ان تتابعنا ان شاء الله
تفضلي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات